what's up guys i'm here at the nikon
experience store at funan in singapore
to try out the all-new nikon zfc it's in
my hands i play with it
let's talk about it
[Music]
okay this can be much more of a vlogging
style session here today but so bear
with me on this but here it is
right here i've been playing with it for
the past half hour and my initial
thoughts on it
this is really a beautiful camera it's
based off the fm2 that a lot of you know
out there in the film days if you don't
do your research we'll actually give you
a show you some shots of what the fm2
looks like but it's been modernized
quite a bit it has a lot of the
internals of the z50
but in a much more robust more retro
more just better fueling body in my
personal opinion so with the zfc a lot
of people have this question what does
the fc stand for well according to nikon
f is for fusion c is for casual because
they're looking at more of the novice
photographer but a fusion with the
original fm2 which is a beautiful camera
so now let's talk about some of the
specs that you should know about this
camera first off we've got uh this comes
and it's sort of a magnesium alloy body
here it's got this plastic sort of uh
i would say
faux vulcanite material around it okay
and it also goes covers here in the back
into the camera as well we look at that
right there so this has a very retro
feel and actually on the back of the
display here you'll find that as well so
you're gonna see that uh
full vulcanite right there and it gives
a really nice retro feel when you look
at the top of the camera this is where
it's really unique because when we look
at the top here you're going to see that
vulcanite look there with the dials
everything looks absolutely beautiful
this is a really well built
well-designed camera and it's a lot
larger than i thought it was going to be
because the z50 does feel quite small in
my hands but the
zfc feels a lot more robust it feels
well it's actually as i was told the
same size as the fm2 so if you have an
fm2 at home and you're looking for a
digital version of that to play around
with there you have it here with the zfc
now moving to the front of it of course
you have that nikon logo embossed in
there with black paint it's beautiful
it's retro it is stylish and of course
we've got our
dials here which are all really well uh
designed they got this ridge on the side
of it which feels really good easy to
turn around on that we've got our
shutter speed we got exposure and that
little window there is for your aperture
okay and your iso right there so all
looks really good and then you got your
rear evf on that it's a 2.36 million dot
evf on that this is a 20 megapixel aps-c
sensor in this camera system of course
you're going to probably notice one of
the things here about this is the flip
out rotatable display on the camera
system and that is something new from
nikon which is a nice attribute if you
want to do some vlogging some video and
you want to be able to see how you're
framed up this really does come in handy
even for photographers out there if you
want to capture some interesting angles
with this display this helps you enable
that then of course on the camera system
we have the very highly desired 28
millimeter f 2.8 prime lens this is a
full frame lens in very retro styling so
the question a lot of people are asking
now is with the zfc being an aps-c
sensor and then we have a full-frame
lens that matches the body beautifully
could we see a full-frame version of
this camera all right let's talk about
the video specs here on the zfc really
quick for those of you who want to use
this for a video now
most of you will probably use this for
photography because of the design
element but if you want to use video for
it you can 4k to 30 frames per second
you can use the entire sensor for this
1080 up to 120 on this
you've got your eye tracking your great
auto focus all that is in the video
functionality so that's going to cover
with the photography and with the video
as well so my final thoughts on the
camera system is that it really is uh
and it's an interesting move by nikon
yes a lot of people are gonna say it's
competing with fujifilm but if you
really look at nikon's history these are
the kind of cameras they used to make
years ago
and with this uh
ode to the fm2
this is a really unique camera system
and i mean the dials feel great the
buttons feel great uh the ergonomics
while it doesn't have a grip on it right
now maybe it'll come with an accessory
in the future it feels really robust in
the hands
now i couldn't share any photos in this
video unfortunately we're not allowed to
take any out of the sd card but for my
uh from what i saw
i have to say that great color science
that uh great auto focusing that we saw
on the z50 it's all in this camera
system but it looks so much better and i
have a feeling that this is the
beginning of this retro theme from nikon
i
think
a full-frame version of this may be
coming out sooner than we think
nobody's telling me that
but based on that 28 millimeter of 2.8
lens with that vintage inspired look
which is a full-frame lens
that doesn't match is z62 or z72
i'm just putting two to two together
anyway those are my final thoughts on
the camera system right now let us know
what you'd like to see in the full
review and let us know any comments you
have any questions you have i'll try to
answer those for you with that guys stay
safe take care and i'll chat you in the
next one bye
[Music]
you